you don't stay married to somebody or be
with somebody for four to five years and
it's just based off of you getting high
off the ecstasy kim kardashian's first
husband damon thomas is reacting to her
claim that she was high on ecstasy when
they got married that doesn't make any
sense at all so i think that's a
very irresponsible thing to say given
our children go to the same school
the music producer who eloped in las
vegas with kim when she was 19 and he
was 29 is talking about this 2018
episode of keeping up with the
kardashians
where she said she was using the party
drug at the time of the paris nuptials
in 2000. i got married on ecstasy i had
no idea no the first time i did ecstasy
once and i got married yeah i don't
remember that at all
and damon says his relationship with the
beauty mogul was way deeper than what
she's maintained over the years i mean
it was this young love you know you can
kind of kind of because it happened in
the past you can try to sweep it under
the rug but you don't stay married to
somebody or be with somebody for four to
five years and it's just based off of
you getting high off the exit you know
what i mean that doesn't make any sense
at all the songwriter also thinks kim
should take their families into
consideration when she talks about the
marriage i think it's unfair to make
those kind of blanket statements
um
because we have kids you know you know i
have children my kid goes to the same
school her kid goes to so imagine him
when he has to deal with that at school
i think that she should be more
responsible with those statements
because there's a lot more to
that subject and those things and i've
been very responsible in not talking
about
what that marriage was or what it meant
to me still at the end of the day damon
has nothing but nice words to say about
her at this point first of all let's
talk about kim i'm proud of her i'm
proud of her family i've seen chris i've
seen chris at kenny's wedding i've seen
you know and we all speaking since
divorcing damon back in 2004 kim got
married two more times first to chris
humphries in 2011 they split after 72
days as husband and wife but weren't
officially divorced until 2013. the next
year kim married kanye west but now
they're in the middle of a divorce and
how do you talk to your children about
it i'm really open and honest with them
you know the younger ones don't
understand as much when it comes to
family i mean
kanye and i will always be family of
course it's all played out on the
family's reality shows we've filmed
everything from
deliveries to
marriages divorces we you know have
always stayed true to who we are and
always
shared
pretty much everything so that's just
who we've been and i don't
you know i think there's like
something really courageous in that
and now kim seems happier than ever with
her current beau pete davidson i like
you just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
and that moment that sparked it all is
something we'll see more of on the
family's new hulu series
what do you love about him what's your
favorite thing about him
um he's just super genuine yeah and it's
just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
that's my favorite thing
that's the goal is finding someone to do
nothing with it's the best because you
can do everything totally but it's crazy
to be distracted with people you can be
with anyone
distracted but you can't be with anyone
and do nothing
[Music]